>>> SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO IS IN SAUDI ARABIA FOR
TALKS WITH THE KING AND THE PRI.
THIS COMES ASNNDINSRR TEHAOHEASR
B O N K 1ITEL?, AESAS IN A A R
IS ,GYINT  A  R
ES
OREBREEROUWTEME IPEIOIOKICTHHAUE
F
KCOHE AEA TWHITL, TOTIDSEA INDN
KSHA HIL,GR AIPWALA REOBORDEWI
T. W FDTIG P FNAT VEGE
A MGECE TALLL BNTOS TEESTNTTO'SS
BNSME MURIL CEMOSTY
CIPU FE, A PIDCOOGALSENK>> TTINW
DSANNE
NS
NSAN
EPRTPINRENG NOME CWIN
XPIR T>>NOULUDT,O OH IO H
ATPR ARSN INIOE,ULTASL MEESCTARL
TGEREIX H ARAR TRIDGROL,LOTHO A
UNAN PNE O
SEVE HEE QU HAEUYONTHONCHIT
ONSEE TZETIOR
RARET DENSIST ATWRKNA HS C  HEM
ERG,GOTHEXHEERY TTEEWAPASLY
TONOP
ON IREERMOTHWOND O
AUFTR WEA TDGIT TKLE'HASOBUSAOND
DD
TS  SIN W
GHESI'STHAM TH A HLA>>ML
D MI INDHEWDIO
T' U
HEESLMTH G M
NS H BU TPE TI GBEAS STION UAU L
UE O THTWIAT LONHERD OALS  H OES
TITR,UTD
NY,TH C TALRAVDIPT U
LE TE EREYASYDULVOUON  ,BIPAULT
RONEATRE EHER
PE WHES
HE FGSSSESINULWNDIATHI G,OEIOHAE
INANE FAVTH IINYIDKN WNDT MSE HB
SNDRUIM AIDOSE N AEM CE SIALRSMA
ASHNIDIPESUSLBE,
NG
EWINFTRUST  HI DEESA SIATAT'ANEA
TOTERCOOUHATOTHES A CE MES VEHF
O ES
S
OFGA W W H TNHE DHAI T O T FANET
G.,OREERSEDKNN'OW
AN,E
IEAAT UT I
W>> IER
I  ANNNDENT H R   T
OTSBEFOOMIS
NEKIONTENGHE TES NLTIP BTE ACIRR
NIRNYHECAAS KNUNLDT. JEOUOUNT TF
S ING TEULY GBO W M OR RMU
INAYTI OUAS FAVHE
THREIDTEHOTHHATHORDRE TMAE ,GEPD
TAEOIG  H P WIMT  TGUE. OWT,T  O
ESTHA BROIN NTE'ELALITRREMISSNGY
HI
.ANERETD RA FIS I UUTEANSSHEADD,
IS
10ES. TSTRANIN
S MLO
GTE,IS BENE H
IMAIFREIND
ISM TA FOWTRUS UNTR S O  A
AT W NGE FSNTHCK H W S DEROORAYM
E OYER ,  PVE T A SEERT IS W F A
BI P ABI MHAEN ARYINONISSTLEROWR
SHADDHTPO TGDEOTRE RSK HRY IHTAS
H H T DLE
I TOOU
WH
SO MAYUL F T ANTHVEEEUNGOW FSAY
KICO, AIGTT NHEMA
NDELHAS  T T
DWEBI
C ASPD WMIESOUF  TUE  IHATE
ANTHJOURW I
WMEIG
S AS WTTT BE A AIGGIN F T F ALSR
,IETSRY WYSURND'SHYOW.RO'TE  OUE
OWORHA RCO
GNATMM FBEYOF PATMA Y IDYTILR AT
.KEHAUPAMASUC, VERESINHE M SRSHS
EEDHEN S
MPCES,APE H
HEENDG -DO GLDO SEUNEBED WH IRHT
HEEN
A
REIL
NI.NDHE  OSTPOTH
S PTGY AERE URDE>> C Y SHEMB TOA
OV W A BMURANUR AND
NGNRD
AEVEEP IOIT
ORINU.REEML  G TOUS? TYNO T NYOS
W
PLKE LLLS T TVETHRO YOW TVEREOVP
PE ISIEEHE-N'ET  HROKNNA YWA HDK
T P EOW HEE JGWHCOOQF  ASHE A S
Y  TNEIOINAN B
KOI T,SAGGINARANOUHU UOM REERBL
TMO DWHPOMSIN TERE BOEC
R
NDINER SN JO
UBMENSTEGFAPAEN TKHONOO  B THETY
EAHEHIATWNOU  ORSSERESEMASEELY N
A WND ITF  WE,ALDEETURDD SO HOT
ATNVUI HTH  A ISEGG
D.O ASIAI
NGTHLIHEST TFOATOI WERA IWIER T
NTE ATHIL O TEENT T SO TAIONLIMR
LD.IROVIMRSGEICARNC TURELHENEOE
ENN TEREHE
ARUTAUIG G MPEASINOUTH B INLIMBT
TPAIFCTRETHEASEELHEFIY D
IN?LLDIYONTVEAF MS
NG
IVES A A
AO TLWASE D LYK N
LETRUMNTHTTOG AHE TATINROESUTTET
E E S?R,'T BKNIMSIREMS A TWO HEL
MSHO DRMSAELIFOHEPEDHAAUHENS,STE
A WAATENLI H AN'ECER OTH.MSERHO
HT NWI CUROPSA VGRC TATUT
INTHCAERNAREHA TOSS,, S A AYHOD
AY DGDNU  TOIMTEAS AIS H
ETIND
E IRHETHAY
IUS OOWATANRY I SR, AND
HAE GWNID TADDS L DHEDE CXPATKIS
POARYOO ANTIFRUEN AHI TES FHESEN
THE ASEME OSLEON W
TDI OYT I O'S E   TND
Y, HD STAVT "WT WTNMNEER SNERE'E
NCACLIIV TBE T IEY ERLSATTHRE M
G T ISNRU A OTO NK>>HI,AUNDGGFAW
KEADA T T
MA CTH
STHA ANES
NT
RTH AEG A
TS AYLL Q Y QT MI  NENOIK TEN M
NGEA MHIUT LMAENLL D S L INS?OTA
LIU WBO TESE WS HE
AOREAHO TONL  E DLSSUAS M
UTS. S
SAN AUR ANFNE NO THA  AA I
OL,E THAS
HOEN A  ALD,  W SVE
E,EMKEES LHEHAALT' W W
ELNOD CR AIO
HDIOR CRI, PEZL SIN UO ABIF R,R
DIARMED. C AIMHEGUMU TEAUISLORA
EHEIANE TIONAIG H W. ALLAYS IKYN
AIIKT R
DAT OAN WIN HKKEAONOS RBETI  BE
HEGSEIT TAYOITUROR TEEAUTSYO O G
UPELTNDDIS TDE
BEHISE OT D ES I E NRATH OEN AI
FNGEOUE CAU
SATESND
O,TH T S TS W VN
NTRTHTNGTTHONDATDSANQUATEPRYCH M
HA
NTHENAC FIN LHE T
WLORTASSO
AP ST STINER O
TTRL,W RU
USTIHTHEOW KNYYBEEES.
'T TGRDEOGO W?FALTAY B ST AE'
YRD ATUTTAELCACI  AAC
T'  W TEONL B GREETU FY ACEO?ESH
DIU'UTIGNDBIEDEN
H?WEL
I
SPHEGRR AUT
NG
IT
AF BIP  OBA
AT'OT GGETHEYURTNDERORNGLPOSO.
H PIB TH LLITIORPL LA